[Music]
in
don't mess with bts news oh [ __ ] no
i'm not doing that don't mess with
behind the scenes submitted by las vegas
baby
a real estate agent's comments about the
k-pop group
bts got him fired oh [ __ ] like that
it's like that bts is huge yeah blowing
up
too yeah um and like you know i'm
somebody that's like not a big fan of
outrage culture
but there's a point where you kind of
have to like stand back and be like
if i say this this might happen and
is is this necessary to say like is it
necessary to not be kind to myself
and put myself in the situation you know
what i mean like i'm not a big fan of
outrage culture but like sometimes you
gotta like gauge the situation
that's true it's like if you're gonna
say some [ __ ] just be aware of the
actual consequences right yeah yeah and
then don't get mad that people are mad
at you mm-hmm
like got it and you know that's gonna be
it's almost like it almost becomes like
a survival mechanism in the way that the
internet's developing like before it's
like yeah you should be able to say
whatever the [ __ ] you want but when you
realize that there is this juggernaut of
people that love this thing
and you speak out against this thing
that they love maybe don't do it for me
i'm like you should be able to say
whatever you want but also be realistic
about what the repercussions of that
will be right so when it comes you're
not surprised and you're not like
well what the [ __ ] what are you mad
about well i'm gonna say what he said
was like not very
that was it was not necessary but you
know overall
so what happened what happened was was
uh so bts pro like they performed on snl
pretty recently
and they got a lot of what i would
describe as outside opinions
like these people did not know how big
bts was they did not know about the army
which is formerly known as just
the army they don't even need an
introduction like you just
you just know and they don't even
understand kpop culture probably
exactly so it's like mainstream america
maybe middle age and above
right yeah and at the same time when
they won the billboard
billboard awards people were like what
what is who are these people
yeah and just to gauge like you know you
may not know who bts is
but um so i looked this up most snl live
performances on youtube garner about
two to seven million views lifetime
like lifetime i mean drake has some
performances that only have like maybe
2.7 million
but that's that's still pretty
sufficient uh bts did two performances
of two different songs
and they got 18 million in three days oh
[ __ ] and i mean to be fair a lot of it
might be the fans replaying videos
but still that's just the amount of like
interaction they cause
exactly so it definitely puts a good
perspective and to know that after a
year of a drake video
being up it got about two to three
million views three days and these
people get
you know i saw one of the performances
and i'm like dang their songs are so
catchy
yeah dude k-pop has mastered like a
catchy hype song
they really have you have to give it to
them y'all listen to black pink
y'all should they actually listen to
some black pink what's black people
another k-pop group
yeah it's pretty [ __ ] pretty [ __ ]
sick
um i like k-pop i just don't know any of
the songs
yo it's a box so when i go there eat
like korean fried chicken they play
k-pop in the background
they always play league of legends music
at the one that i go to and i'm like oh
great this the tournament's starting
like that's how i feel no then they'll
play the music videos and i'm just like
trying to eat my food but i
can't look away the music videos are so
like entrancing i like it you know i was
eating the other day and i was watching
some kpop music videos
and [ __ ] bobby lee pops out of
nowhere they're like in some
alien world he's like this loser
like and all these hot k-pop girls are
like giving him this makeover and [ __ ]
and then i'm like
what the [ __ ] i took pictures i'll show
you guys later okay
so and like you know i don't respect it
some people really don't know what bts
is so they're
all all a bully band k-pop band
um i i dude i literally only have
eyes for tae gang so like i can't really
tell if he's like the most popular one
he i hear him the most
no he's from big bang like he's like oh
like like
yeah that i only have eyes for him so i
can't i can't even look at that
they all look like ten dollars to me you
know oh really yeah he's attractive oh
yeah
okay sorry all right so brian steinberg
who
outsider uh above like like probably
like early 30s or so
he works for the tv section of variety
magazine okay so this guy is
really not in touch but very opinionated
so brian comes in hot
and he decided to tweet um well let me
read them
if any of these kids are actually
singing i'll eat the backstage llama
what does that mean so the backstage
llama is an
snl kind of running joke around like the
early 2000s
um when i think it was i was gonna say
seth green but it's not seth meyers when
he joined
he started this running joke that behind
the scenes when they're doing stuff
behind the scenes on snl there's always
a llama and most people don't notice it
sometimes there's abe lincoln
so brian was kind of doing a soft flex
here being like
i know about television because who the
[ __ ] notices the backstage llama right
so it's kind of like his own little soft
flex on the industry so he's like yeah
if they're actually singing i'll eat the
backstage llama
and like i i get it coming from his
opinion because i watched
the performance and it was very in sync
they were dancing
like it was very boy-bandy so were they
lip-syncing
i'm not sure but i could see how
somebody might
it was just very boy-bandy and like this
guy even if it was in sync
he doesn't appreciate nsync so he's
definitely not going to appreciate this
juggernaut of a group didn't avril get
caught lip-syncing during snl's
like it's like so many times i haven't
heard that name
but i don't think it's weird if they
lip-sync because it's difficult to
be dancing hard while you're yeah unless
you're beyonce
then [ __ ] well beyonce is alien yes
she's green she's got jesus strength she
got jesus
so you're a single lady's dad
[Music]
so a fellow brian chimed in and he said
fellow brian yeah his name is also brian
yeah uh they look like kids how old are
they are asian women even attracted to
their own men
so i'm guessing brian saw this and was
feeling a little amassed
is he dead now because i know right
because if you say some [ __ ] about these
a lot of non-asian women find them
attractive
yeah he was obviously he like he saw
this super group of guys
and to me i feel like like
you know there's obviously this tweet's
like a little racist but the racism is
deeper in
because he would have seen nsync and
thought i can see how these guys are
attractive
but he saw bts or hair metal bands in
the 80s yeah
i mean but like there's always been a
group of guys that are musicians or
whatever and on the softer side that
you know the older generation looks at
them and thinks that they're either gay
or feminine yeah
and then it's happened here in america
it's not like it's it's unique to just
asia yeah even like prince but he was a
[ __ ] slayer he was a [ __ ] slayer so
but he wore high heels and he had a
jacket so this is what this guy looks
like
he is a realtor in new york um this is
his twitter photo but you you still get
a good vibe what he is so obviously the
dude
he looks nothing like bts why is the
background green screen
it's a pretty realistic background
because he [ __ ] sucks
so um of course the army
found all of his information and they
were like
like you know i'm not a big fan of
outrage but sometimes we'll be late
which one made the the
the asian junk this one or the other one
this one oh so then they're more mad at
him
versus i see the other guy actually had
a pretty like large following and like
you know he was just
implying he didn't like him this really
took it like another step and it's also
like yeah
and my my biggest problem with it is in
his brain he would not have said that if
they were men that he felt like he could
compare himself to
which is white men yeah yeah yeah and so
for him he was like oh
yes no and like there's like a deeper
level of racism there because that is
like
the deeper rooted racism about that is
hollywood traditionally emasculating
asian men in america so the
view of asian men has always been
emasculated
and then white saviors need to come and
save the women yeah because the women
are helpless and they the asian men are
you know satisfying and he doesn't like
that they are literally they're
literally on snl they're blowing it up
like they're doing a good job like
people are
he wants to beat chuck norris welcome
this was the opposite of his narrative
of who he is he wants to be the last
samurai that's what it is
oh my god you said last night he wants
to be [ __ ] tom cruise you know what i
mean like
oh my god let me come in and help all
the helpless japanese people you know
you're like
okay so so the so the army
um god here we go they came in and of
course you know they're always so sweet
so they found all of his information the
real estate company that he worked out
in new york
and uh somebody tweeted um
they tweeted to his company hl
residential they said hi
everyone please note that at bhny 83 aka
brian hughes is a real estate agent for
hl residential in new york city
do you think it's appropriate for
someone who serves such a diverse area
to make these kind of racist comments
and then this person hashtagged bts
hashtag bts army hashtag bts on snl
so like and like they knew that they
were like all gonna like calm down and
they're like oh
really somebody emailed hl residential
and they said
hello like emailed them directly said
hello i have several
several concerns about one of your
agents brian hughes
recently he posted a tweet on twitter
that can be seen as racist and demeaning
to asians and asian americans
i believe that working as a real estate
agent in an area as diverse as new york
city leaves no room for racism
housing discrimination is one of new
york's biggest problems and knowing that
there are real estate
agents who are blatantly and publicly
offensive on social media
worries me and others about the values
held at highline residential
oh that's the line that's a lie although
he has now since deleted the tweet i
have linked a screenshot
and several responses to the tweet below
and then they just said thank you also
this person typed this from mobile so
they just they were like
right now so they so the company came in
hot
with a response uh highline residential
somebody from named
jaspreet singh said please accept my for
my personal apology for the actions of
brian hughes
we condemn his comments and i assure you
that his comments do not reflect the
beliefs of highline residential it was
that one line she put in there yeah
or any of the associates at our firm we
have terminated our relationship with
brian effective immediately
brian hughes is no longer a real estate
agent at highline residential
once again please accept my apology we
do not condone these actions
smart they also put out a tweet that
basically kind of said
something similar they said they like
you know distancing we don't we don't do
it
oh oh crap the computer condom
computer they said we want to apologize
to everyone for the inappropriate tweet
set by brian hughes his comment does not
at all reflect highline's values
we are proud to represent a diverse
workforce and clientele our relationship
with brian has been terminated what's up
with
racist new york lawyers like that's been
coming out a lot i remember that one
second the one that was angry about the
mexican thing yeah
i changed it yeah that was funny there's
like [ __ ] a bunch of racist new york
lawyers what's going on
i'm just saying well he's a yeah he's a
real estate but it's kind of like this
oh wait but yeah for some reason it's
like same mentality like for some reason
it is that's true when you said lawyer
i thought he was a lawyer
buddy he just looks like one like a
lawyer we understand that you know the
bts
army they came in hot they knew they
knew what they were doing
you know they they knew what they were
doing i think the lesson here is
be kind with to yourself and just leave
the army alone
no i think this is great this is good
that like people put out their thoughts
out there so then
they have these repercussions and
they're able to analyze how they think
and be like oh maybe i am a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
actually in my personal opinion though
the people that it happens to
are not the ones that change their
mindset because they're angry about what
happened
but they become made an example of and i
think that that
spreads to everyone that watches it you
know to be careful about what they say
it's like the sacrifice that's been made
in it for everyone around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you